[Music]
chance and tea is accompanying the
coffins of the three Kurdish refugees
killed in Paris on December the 23rd
the funeral seems to have United the
Kurdish Community across Europe
thousands gathered in a Parisian suburb
to pay their respect
many have come from other regions of
France and neighboring countries
the community is disappointed and Afraid
after the Kurds were shot dead in the
10th District of the city which is home
to a large Kurdish community
relatives of the dead and activists say
they're insulted as Kurds and as French
citizens because they feel the state has
failed in its obligations
we want Justice and Truth we are used to
conspiracies in Turkey but in France we
would like to know what's behind this
who did the killer meet when he was in
prison who is really this person being
called a Madman we want answers
are from Syria Iran Iraq and turkey
they're also angry at the governments in
their home countries the Gathering
provided an opportunity to express their
political views as well
we thought Kurds flame repression would
be safe in Europe but when we are
targeted in the heart of Paris that
raises questions on how we see European
countries
their anger is also directed at French
authorities for not declaring it a
terrorist attack and some politicians
agree
the French state must be more
transparent the fact that the crime is
qualified as a terror attack shouldn't
be related to the color of the skin of
the perpetrators every racist attack is
a political act and a terror attack
the 69 year old white male accused of
the murders is awaiting a formal
investigation in trial the bodies will
now be taken to the Kurdish region of
Northern Iraq and turkey for burial
January marks 10 years since the killing
of three activists in Paris and these
latest three killings have reopened all
wounds they've been demanding an
investigation for the last decade but
are afraid that once again they're dead
will not get Justice
era Harris